quiero hablar un poco de sentido común
porque a veces siento que es algo que
hemos perdido como sociedad y yo no sólo
lo veo en costa rica yo lo veo en todos
lados esta es una imagen en londres del
absoluto molote que se sucede ustedes en
el mero centro y hoy a otras ciudades
como españa
a veces madrid me da esperanzas de que
todavía el ser humano es lo más
importante de que el noveno el automóvil
no la máquina sino que nosotros somos
los más importantes heras por dicha
tenemos estos ejemplos que podemos
pensar pero para mí este mi pasión mi
corazón está en costa rica yo no puedo
dejar de pensar en mi país sinceramente
trato de ver cómo hago para hacer
proyectos acá a toda costa me acuerdo yo
he ido mucho limón y me acuerdo de estas
casas en maderas en que están verdades
en pilotes y ahora las casas nuevas las
están construyendo en zonas y municiones
pegadas al piso verdad este está falta
donde donde hubo un cambio que pasó como
donde perdimos el sentido común a tal
punto que que hasta nuestra propia
supervivencia está en riesgo
que quiero que enseñarles unos ejemplos
de cosas que hemos hecho que estamos
trabajando en londres con el arquitecto
richard rogers del cual soy asociado
este es un complejo en inglaterra este
es el tipo de vivienda de interés social
que se está que se ha generado en los
años 80 y nosotros este queremos
participar en con los mismos
presupuestos de bien entera social a ver
qué podíamos hacer nosotros cómo
podíamos humanizar esto que es tan
lúgubre hay un ventanitas chiquititas
espacios completamente inhumanos
nosotros empezamos a generar este tipo
de arquitectura el mismo presupuesto
está que esas casas están construidas
con el mismo material que se hace en las
mesas de mcdonald's esta materia que se
llama 3 para y se le da una
individualidad a cada persona se debe
ser cada persona ahora tiene un nuevo
lugar que es con aire y ventilación
natural iluminación natural no tiene que
aprender la luz lo del sentido común o
más obvio lo que debería ser de un
principio y usando los mismos
presupuestos o sea hubo que ver cómo se
hacía con el material más barato y que
fuera excelente para nosotros este ahora
es un orgullo que que la gente ahora
quiera vivir ahí que esté
que esté orgulloso de su hogar y que la
gente quiera venir ahora bien valen más
plata y ya no son viviendas de ese tipo
el re puerto de barajas
este es el aeropuerto que se terminó
hace unos años eso es lo que nosotros
sabemos que es un aeropuerto verdad un
lugar apiñado lleno de gente sin exit
ventilación y sin iluminación natural
para nosotros es importante que cuando
uno esté no se agrandó la maleta le esté
pegando el solcito en la piel tal vez
eso es lo que yo llevo a esta compañía
no sé pero para mí es importante que
estar con esa conexión con el exterior
no estar en este en esta máquina
completamente inhumana pero nosotros
humanizar el espacio iluminaciones
naturales se bajan costos como cuando un
aliciente vas a no vas a tener que pagar
menos electricidad vas a tener que
íbamos a usar el mismo presupuesto que
cualquier otro aeropuerto no es que
vamos a gastar más plata no es que los
arquitectos estamos aquí para
despilfarrar con cosas lindas que con
los mismos presupuestos podemos hacer
exactamente lo mismo y hasta mejor el
guys en tanto más cosas pitón en la
tierra también es un hospital que es
esto verdad es un absoluto búnker
imagina segundo estar ahí con una con
una pariente sufriendo horroroso uno no
saben en qué piso es cuál es
concreto todos nosotros empezamos a
pensar en esta idea cómo hacemos
edificios en altura que sean humanos
digamos un 9 el edificio y uno no saben
en qué piso hasta uno pero como aseguró
para humanizar el espacio empezamos a
hacer villas en el aire por ejemplo cada
una de las villas es por ejemplo
quimioterapia radioterapia es un espacio
para el cant para rehabilitación del
cáncer consejería digamos tal vez los
tres pisos es un espacio suficientemente
humano ya después de ahí se empieza a
hacer en una mole de concreto el spa el
edificio empieza a expresar por fuera lo
que está pasando dentro de espacios en
terceras alturas y empieza a decir cada
uno de estos espacios es eso es algo se
entiendo desde afuera es legible para
nosotros era importante apartarnos del
paradigma de que un hospital es esto era
un espacio horrible donde uno nada más
transita y no sabe ni dónde está el
norte verdad nosotros queríamos pensar
que el espacio interior de un hospital o
de un centro de rehabilitación podía ser
mejor nuestra imagen importante seguimos
prototipo de vivienda vertical entonces
para mí es importante está bien estamos
afuera en practicando y haciendo lo
mejor posible por los demás
queríamos ver cómo podíamos hacer algo
en costa rica cómo podíamos empezar a
proponer cosas aquí que hacemos
empezamos a inventar nos pasamos a
buscar clientes bueno una vez es el
prototipo de vivienda vertical para san
josé y nosotros sabemos que esto es lo
que más o menos está empezando a
artesanos algunas unas cajas de concreto
con un balcón citó que nadie gusta dónde
se pone la basura o la bicicleta si es
que alguien usa la bicicleta este
nosotros pensamos que este que para
hacer que lo mejor que podemos hacer es
utilizar el mismo presupuesto que estos
edificios no podemos empezar a jugar de
locos porque no se hacen simples ella
mente cómo hacemos para reconfigurar los
mismos espacios de una edificación como
esa en una edificación mejor entonces en
este lado es una planta de un edificio
tradicional hay un núcleo todo el núcleo
es en negro el azul es la circulación y
es para los espacios hay cuatro puertas
uno no sabe ni dónde está y los
bastoncitos nosotros decimos por qué no
usamos ese núcleo y mezclamos la
circulación azul con un balcón antes de
entrar a la habitación o sea entrar por
medio de lo que es una terraza nosotros
sabemos muy bien lo que es eso vemos
hemos vivido así durante muchísimos años
entramos por una terraza llena
llena de vegetación nos encanta estar en
comunicación con el exterior
no sé cómo hacemos para llevar la
tipología de la de la casa de campo que
nosotros añoramos tanto y por eso es que
nos vamos a vivir afuera sanjosé y
andamos una hora y media en automóvil
para llegar al centro porque no vivimos
en el centro y no tenemos que andar en
el carro pero claro queremos vivir con
una armonía con naturaleza en nuestro
campo cómodos bueno
tenemos un montón de casas encima de una
cima de otra este el resultado de esto
es este bueno queremos también integrar
un jardín un jardín un jardín vertical
un elemento que pudiera también ser algo
este que era de comer a los habitantes
de este edificio
esta es la tipología es realmente en
aquí en este ejemplo se ven cuatro
módulos pero realmente se puede poner un
módulo o dos módulos realmente es una
manera de pensar que se puede aplicar en
muchas propiedades pero la idea es que
en este balcón todo el mundo tenga la
relación con la calle que todo el mundo
tenga esta vegetación enfrente que tengo
que hacer un filtro hacia el exterior
que haya comercio que vayan que haya una
mezcla de usos que nosotros no sólo sea
yo voy a mi casa y después tengo que ir
a trabajar quién sabe dónde también yo
puedo comer aquí tal vez yo puedo vivir
aquí trabajar
y puedo hacer de todo eso es la planta
distribución uno llega al elevador y
después después entra por esta terraza
al interior obviamente la circulación se
convirtió en terraza por ende los mismos
espacios de circulación ya no son
circulación jazz ya es otra cosa
queremos pasar de esto que es espantoso
a esto tal vez esto se puede hacer en
nuestras latitudes porque nosotros no
nos jugamos con lo que ya tenemos porque
no vivimos la vida que queremos vivir
como hacemos para cambiar el paradigma
con los mismos presupuestos y las mismas
ideas
la tecnología tiene que tener sentido y
en este edificio tenía que ser
sostenible de todo punto de vista
este vemos edificaciones como estas que
son se tienen los más altos grados de
certificaciones ecológicas que se le
ponen sobre unos paneles de
fotovoltaicas a la típica caja horrorosa
con un montón de escritorios verdadera
no sé a quién quiere estar ahí nosotros
no creemos que la tecnología se tiene
que usar de esa manera más bien nosotros
creemos en la tecnología para tratar de
hacer edificaciones que no gasten y que
sean cómodas y que no se prende la luz y
que la temperatura sea cómoda y que haya
neste ventilación es naturales y que no
haya que utilizar la tecnología la
tecnología se no se utiliza
y no un remedio no un maquillaje para
nosotros es importante es el yo común
usar la tecnología para lo que es bueno
yo quería como éste ahora llegar digamos
a proyectos ya concretos yo sé que no he
hecho mucho aquí en costa rica pero aquí
estamos viendo cada vez más este este
proyecto es de unos amigos míos que
ellos bueno conocer en una recesión uno
de ellos seco sin trabajo tenía una
deuda muy grande viven en una casa con
un montón de cuartos y de todo y de ahí
estén y estaba un poco ahogados verdad y
tenían una propiedad
y yo el día porque no se van allí y se
van a vivir esa propiedad que está
afuera de las afueras de san josé y así
vienen un huevito viven así en algo
chiquitito que importa
ustedes ocupan todos los cuartos de
visitas el cuarto televisión todo ese
montón de cosas al final eso que los
hace felices estar con un hasta el
cuello porque no nada más están nada más
tranquilos y viven en algo más humilde
entre comillas verdad hagamos algo
razonable y dieron bueno hagamos la casa
del guarda en un futuro hacemos el chozo
metro verdad
entonces alguien hagamos la casa y
guarda entonces éste agarramos los
contenedores los separamos útil
agarramos los lados del contenedor y los
pusimos como un techo en el centro osea
reconfigura mos el material que ya
existía y sin comprar mucho más para
hacer un espacio cómodo y un espacio
donde circular el aire naturalmente
donde desbloqueará el sol y donde se
sintiera más amplio nadie quiere vivir
en una lata de atún sinceramente este es
el espacio más es muy sencillo sala como
reconocieron su el espacio y el el y la
cama
llegar a los contenedores estaban
destartalados herrumbrados todo lo que
ustedes quieren es espantoso yo con
miedo esto no va a servir o sea que
estoy haciendo está embarcando a la
gente este día pero requiere que gente
con visión también no es que yo sea el
que propone tiene que ser el cliente
también conmigo que nos tiremos al agua
y a ver qué sale este es el producto el
producto es una casa ya para ellos en la
cual no se quieren mover ahí quieren
vivir el resto de su vida y esto es este
es el este es su sala desde afuera le
van a poner un deck ahí enfrente todavía
no tienen la platita este yo creo que
tal vez lo pusiéramos a éste
realmente es bastante cómoda realmente
es un espacio digno de vivir y yo
viviría ahí yo no crearía nada en lo
cual yo no viviría yo mismo y ellos
están muy contentos o sea la ventilación
dice que nunca han tenido que aprender
el aire acondicionado es en ciudad colón
que todos sabemos que en esta época es
un horno el espacio es muy agradable se
ve el se ve el atardecer se ven amanecer
para mí es esta imagen es muy refleja
mucho este átomo andrés garcía el acné
pero es esa sensación de que ellos están
felices ahí con su perro viendo el
atardecer están contentos no tienen
deudas tan felices van a ir a visitarme
a londres el mundo cambió completamente
con esta caja de latas
realmente para mí lo más importante era
esto que esta casa de aquí nos habíamos
construido a salir en serio no sabíamos
cuánto iba a salir y salió más barata
que una casa en cinchona de 46 mil
dólares estas alguien 40 mil dólares
completamente alista con jacuzzis aire
acondicionado todos los lujos todo lo
que ustedes quieren y claro si se ve
como contenedor desde fuera pero estamos
trabajando ahora en casas que sean
realmente estéticas desde afuera también
porque hay la gente de yo no quiero
ponerle contenedores a todo el mundo
aquí supuestamente yo tenía que poner
una imagen
pero realmente veamos estas imágenes de
adentro esta es una imagen ahora de lo
que estamos generando para una casa de
tres cuartos este con cuatro
contenedores dos está encima de dos sala
comedor cocina es de circulaciones
arriba a los cuartos o sea una casa
cómoda esta casa está haciendo bueno la
primera casa la que vieron de
contenedores explotó miles de personas
me contactan diariamente alredor del
mundo se están construyendo en australia
en todos lados espectacular no lo puedo
creer hasta en áfrica ahora este me han
contactado organizaciones no
gubernamentales en varios países que
quieren usarla como prototipo como para
el interior va a ser diferente parece el
prototipo de la idea del concepto éste
como en se manipule yo en el material el
material de manera creativa este yo
quiero digamos terminar la charla con
este proyecto que fue este para mí el
inicio de todo verdad desde que soy
pequeño realmente tal vez yo quería ser
arquitecto para poder darle una casa a
mi madre que no la pasó bien verdad
cuando ella esté cuando era niño pues no
teníamos mucho dinero y ella más
adelante pues ellos se fue a construir
este hogar
playa bella no se lo hizo a partir de
palos de latas de zinc desharán y ella
vivía contenta y si vivía
sinceramente de que venía alguien pero
estaba como a la interperie y yo como
hijo verdad estudiando en eeuu de las
mejores universidades y todo lo que
estoy haciendo aquí que voy a hacer mi
tesis voy a hacer así stella su precioso
metro una cosa inventada no mientras
mamá estás esta tiene una necesidad
entonces se utilice mi proyecto de tesis
para diseñar una casa mi madre y me
gustaría leerles un cuento que es
realmente la inspiración de cómo fue que
la diseñé porque la diseñé desparecen sí
porque para qué
ok
ella se levanta cuando la luna se va
desapareciendo el gran sonido de los
grillos le recuerda que está arreglada
por el bosque el calor del sol naciente
se filtra por entre las hojas y calienta
los pisos de madera ella sabe que ya es
tiempo de hacer el pan el sonido de los
grillos ha cambiado por el canto de los
pájaros la estufa calienta el aire y el
oro se disipa por cada hendijas el
bosque mi mamá va afuera a ducharse
debajo del tanque de agua y
repentinamente una pequeña lluvia se
mezcla con su agua ella recorre la casa
a secarse con el calor de la estufa yo
me levanto y me doy cuenta que ya
amaneció el sol está afuera y hay pan
fresco en la mesa puedo ver que mamá
está sembrando una planta de loe en su
sala de alguna manera ella sabe cuál es
el mejor lugar para que crezca los rayos
del sol golpean el techo de zinc ella
abre todas las puertas de datos y
ventanas y el viento empieza a golpear
sus sábanas hindúes también puedo ver
las sábanas recién lavadas que cuelgan
de dos grandes árboles que le dan sombra
a la casa el viento sopla las hojas y
las trae hacia la casa mi mamá siempre
está limpiando pero nunca nada está
limpio no hay mucho que hacer pero ella
se mantiene siempre ocupada con su
artesanía libros de cuarto izquierdista
un puro y una que otra llamada
teléfonica ella se mueve por toda la
casa tratando de encontrar la mejor
señal ella ha encontrado el lugar
perfecto para hablar
entre la puerta principal del árbol ahí
ella ha puesto una roca en la cual se
puede sentar por horas mi mamá me quiere
llevar la playa pero puedo ver que ella
está preocupada de dejar sola la casa
ella esconde algunas de sus posiciones
más preciadas un libro de fotos y los
puros ellos luego pone una rama en
frente de la entrada enciende radio y
deja la puerta bien abierta luego ella
grita adiós nos vemos luego como si
todavía hubiera alguien en la casa a mí
me parece como si yo estuviera diciendo
adiós a la casa y la casa a su vez
murmura entre el bosque mientras nos
alejamos cada vez más y más dentro del
radio caminamos por el bosque desde la
calle de piedra que luego nos lleva a la
playa
mi mamá va a bañarse en el mar y luego
de un rato se sienta la familia para ver
el atardecer y ya está completamente
deslumbrado que lo ha visto cientos de
veces ella me dice que deberíamos volver
a la casa para agarrar los últimos rayos
de sol que nos guía en el camino
empezamos a ver el radio más y más
fuerte y mientras nos acercamos a la
casa la luz del sol se va desvaneciendo
en mi pronto el bosque va estar
iluminado por la luna ya tiene miedo de
que los cría traiga algún intruso
molestarnos las candelas proveen una luz
cambiante mientras ya tocan la guitarra
y ella prepara una cena rápida que es
difícil de comer por la falta de luz la
luz de la luna entra en la casa y yo sé
que pronto ella sabrá dormir ella ha
puesto su cama en una esquina de la casa
para
en una vista directa de la luna mientras
se va a dormir ella se lava la cara y
envuelve su cuerpo acompaña mojados que
le bajan la temperatura puedo ver que la
vista de la luna a la deslumbra cada
noche y que el sonido de los grillos la
pone a dormir de vez en cuando ella se
despierta alerta por el sonido de sus de
las más naturales la única cosa que le
arrolló es la vista iluminada y la luna
moviéndose entre los árboles
entonces
[Aplausos]
ya ella había encontrado su casa que le
iba a dar yo que entonces al final este
es pues realmente yo le di la luna
realmente yo esté diseñé una casa donde
ellos les marcaba la luna mientras y si
dormir y que miente ella supiera que
aunque yo estuviera donde sea que esté
soy yo el que le estoy regalando esa
luna y que mientras llegas a dormir yo
me acuerdo de ella que ella se acuerda
de mí y que la arquitectura es más que
solamente cumplir la función de tener un
lugar que donde no se mueve donde esté
contenta o donde esté pase la brisa y
donde no tenga aire acondicionado es más
que eso es todavía es más que sentido
común la primera vez que vimos la casa
este que vimos la luna voy a volverme
este por medio de este de este cono que
verdad que se abre es el cielo fue
impresionante yo no creía que iba a
servir tampoco fue la primera vez que
creí que tal vez que quiera que al que
algo de lo que yo hago tiene valor y que
realmente éste no es solamente sentido
común era era mucho más era el amor
darle algo a alguien a darle lo que
realmente él quiere respetar quiere las
demás personas sobre todo una madre
verdad este todos los materiales que
ustedes ven acá son de la casa bien
la casa tiene el techo de zinc el de
verdad el de la casa vieja en la madera
de la casa vieja el bambú fue de una
finca que fue regalado
todo era yo construir la casa yo mismo
la tuve que hacer en módulos porque
realmente no tenía la plata para hacerlo
estaba en londres y haciendo platita y
es
la hicimos primero un módulo específicos
del otro y ahora me llaman de bueno y me
escriben de todas partes del mundo que
quieren hacer hoteles con estos módulos
quieren replicar los por todos lados que
quieran hacer o sea veo como que también
hay una replicabilidad del proyecto pero
para mí lo más importante era esto
general de un bosque interno que ya
pudiera estar segura a este asunto de la
seguridad en costa rica es importante
una señora sola y en el bosque que ya
pudiera estar adentro de su casa y que
ella estuviera segura todo está ya
realmente en vez de bambú hay unas
barras de metal y entra la luz como si
fuera el bosque es importante que ella
estuviese se sintiera segura verdad que
ella estuviera feliz y que al mismo
tiempo no entraran de mosquito es verdad
todas esas cosas por supuesto así que no
se meta la lluvia que no entró en
mosquitos sí está bien pero realmente
esa sensación de estar dentro de un
bosque de ver hacia arriba y ver
iluminado el bambú como si fuera hojas
de los árboles verdad y tratando de ver
cómo se inspira uno en la naturaleza en
mi país para brindarle algo más a la
arquitectura que sea más que solo la
función este para mí es un orgullo que
haber participado en el world
architecture festival del año 2010 en el
año 2009
mi jefe esté richard rogers un
arquitecto que hizo el museo pompidou y
bueno proyectos muy grandes ganó el
premio y en el 2010 lo gané yo a los 30
años y con esta casita en costa rica
verdad en contra de todos los
pronósticos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo quería decirles que que seguimos
trabajando tenemos los proyectos pero
qué
esto ganó el premio al amor casa del
mundo y todo esto no porque yo estaba
buscando la fama o porque porque
realmente hay una necesidad de darle
algo a un prójimo después de que yo hice
la casa en mamá de hecho yo dije nunca
voy a poder amar a nadie de esa forma es
mi mamá pero después alguien de los
contenedores y ahora están saliendo
otras cosas y siento que sí que sí puedo
que si puedo brindar a mi país eso y que
eso es reconocido internacionalmente y
que todo si quiere si hacemos las cosas
bien que si creemos que estamos ayudando
a los demás otras personas van a
reconocer y si no lo reconocen que
importa nosotros sabemos y nos vamos a
dormir la noche sabiendo que estamos
haciendo lo mejor que podemos se los
aseguro que eso va a ser espectacular
que tenemos los recursos para hacerlo
con solo el sentido común importa que no
tengamos las tecnologías más grandes que
no tengamos no importa enfoquémonos en
que si tenemos tenemos una belleza
natural tenemos ingenio creatividad
tenemos las ganas enfoquémonos en nada
más hacer las cosas bien hechas para los
demás sino para nuestro propio para
nuestro propio nosotros nosotros mismos
muchísimas gracias al bien por estar
[Música]